[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today yes we
have Jody in Milwaukee hey Jody welcome
to the show
Hi how are you hi we're doing great
thanks for giving us a call how can we
help
hi so um I currently own a condo with my
mother oh no oh no
I don't even know what you're about to
say but oh no
yes so uh I want to get it in my name
within the next year
um and my grandfather is
um wants to give me 15 000 but my mom
said I have to send a hundred percent of
the 15 000 renovating the condo which I
don't think it should be spent that much
because uh I purchased a condo we
purchase condo under market value but
only eight thousand dollars under market
value so I feel like to spend fifteen
thousand dollars in renovations I don't
even know if it would resell for that
much
yeah how much did you spend on the condo
um so it's a one-bedroom condo we spent
66 000 and they're selling for like 72.
okay and you're with your and you that
you took out a mortgage is it just your
name on the mortgage
no it's both of our names both names
whose names are on the deed
uh my mother's
your mom's okay yeah so I'm telling you
this Jody Rachel you tell me if I'm
wrong but I'm telling you this Jody for
the sake of your soul and if you happen
to have kids their soul and your
relationship with your mom long term
I would do what I could to sell
my part of that or to get out of the
deal or to walk away
because it's gonna collapse your it's
going to collapse your relationship with
your mom and a one bedroom condo for
seventy two thousand dollars is is not
worth that there's no condo worth your
relationship with your mom
but this is just gonna be the beginning
of it
yes do you feel that Jody or do you feel
or would you say no John everything's
great like we have a great relationship
it's fine
yeah um it's been a little difficult
um but she's telling me where to spend
my money or what needs to be renovated
and I pay a hundred percent of the
mortgage yeah
no no no no no then we're selling 100 of
that of the condo if you're paying for
it what is she contributing to it
um well basically I didn't have much of
a credit score so she uh kind of put in
her name for me so I have like a a year
and a half to get in my name but I paid
100 of the mortgage in the HOA fees but
she lives there
yeah I live here she doesn't live here
oh she's not living with you no oh okay
so you live in the condo yes okay so you
need to refinance and get her name off
the mortgage correct yes okay the issue
is I want to refinance and use the money
my grandfather wants to give me but she
uh yes she doesn't get it she doesn't
get a vote yeah that's the complication
she just became his uh POA like just a
couple weeks ago then listen if your mom
is going to steal the money that your
granddad earmarked for you
yeah then walk away from that
relationship she is opting out of
relationship with her daughter if she
steals the money that was earmarked for
for you she doesn't get a vote in that
money her your granddad did not leave
you money you money for her to tell you
but run all your purchase Decisions by
your mom he said I love my granddaughter
I trust her she's been really special
and I'm gonna bless her with fifteen
thousand dollars and you want to spend
fifteen thousand dollars to take your
mortgage which is smart
thank you so no I I if your mom steals
your money I would walk away from my mom
okay and listen I am not saying that
lightly I understand how devastating
that is to say out loud into here
why does she care so much Jody why I
mean I don't understand it's not like
you're saying I'm gonna go to Europe for
fifteen thousand dollars and have the
time of my life what's her what's her
reasoning do you know I have no idea she
comes to my house and tells me what what
needs to be replaced and see first that
she's going to refinance in both of our
names so I don't know if she's going to
try to do a Cash out refinance I don't
know her plans but she just kept saying
well let's just uh refinance and vote
for our names for now until you can get
in your name no no no no no do that no
no
yeah I think Jody I think there's going
to be up to a really blunt kind
hard conversation with her and you're
gonna and John's the perfect one to be
sitting next to me to tell you how to
walk through that conversation but you
need to have some very clear boundaries
with your mom and I think you can be
very kind about it Jody but I think you
need to say Ma how old are you Jody
I'm 27. okay Joe to you're 27. mom I'm
27 years old I is this is this too
passive aggressive John but I would be
like you're a total vocal tone is yes
we're not passive aggressive is this too
kind because if I'm Jody and my mom is
doing this because her mom I would think
your mom's not a malicious person she
probably is thinking I'm helping her
she's played this role in your life for
27 years and I think the conversation is
Mom I I appreciate you wanting to help
me and I appreciate your input and what
you say and you know what Mom you're
probably right you're saying I need to
replace my microwave I probably do thank
you but Mom I'm 27 years old and I'm
gonna start to stand on my own two feet
which means I don't want and put for you
right now there may be a time and a
place in life that I open that door back
up because I do appreciate you and who
you are
but right now I'm making my own
decisions about everything and so when
you come over
I'm not going to allow you in my
apartment my condo to tell me what to do
this is my condo and I want you to
respect that and when I go to your house
Mom I don't want to tell you what to do
I don't want that relationship so that's
the boundary I have to set mom in
another part of that boundary is this
money that Grandad has left me and I'm
going to use the money that he left me
to refinance into this name so that
you're off the mortgage and we can have
a more clean relationship because I'm
scared that this is going to be a
Fallout mom I want to do this to protect
our relationship right yeah is that too
kind or is that no because I want to
respect your mom absolutely I think the
key here is everything is about you not
not her
I want you to be my mom not my business
partner and I'm struggling with how
you're my business partner because we
both signed this deal and you want your
business to look like this and I want it
to look like this and I am feeling uh my
relationship with my mom is getting in
trouble and it's not worth any of this
and so I'm going to take that money and
I want to move this house into my name
and your mom that's her job is to come
over and say well you should fix the car
that's fine but I'm not doing any of
that stuff if I can't afford it and if I
don't want to because it's my house and
so I would I when you start lobbing
grenades because you're doing this and
you keep telling me this then she is has
to go on the defensive right she's got
to defend herself and then this thing
gets into a mess and so I would just sit
down there and say I I I need my mom
back and I don't want to be business
partners with you so yeah no you're
right Rachel you're right
your approach is the right way
um but honestly you said she's not
malicious this is bordering on militias
this is boarding on a mom who can't let
go in my right
yes um her only child so she has oh yeah
so
um there may be some magic
and you taking her out for coffee or for
breakfast and putting your arms across
the table and holding your hands and
saying you did a good job
you did a good job and you raised me a
strong powerful young woman but I need
to start making some of these decisions
on my own and learn how to do this or I
I can't keep going to the gym and you
keep lifting the weights for me I've got
to start lifting weights on my own
and sometimes letting a parent know
because they they're there's a lot of
anxious energy they're trying to help
and help and help improve and probably
yeah yeah and it's like hey well you did
your job you did so good now I just need
my mom
I don't need a business partner I don't
need a complaint partner I don't need a
buddy I need my mom and um that may not
work but the next step is I put the
house on the market and I'm moving or
the next step is
um if you steal money from me that my
granddad left me then we're gonna have
some other issues do you see what I'm
saying so Rachel's ideas is perfect
okay how do you think she'd respond to
that Jody not well
I have no I've tried to have
conversations with her before so we'll
see oh shoot I want you to think of it
this way
if you hold your boundary after you are
clear about it and she violates that
boundary mom I do not want to talk about
X I don't want to talk about why I'm not
going to do this and she chooses to
force that on you she is the one opting
out of relationship with you not the
other way around the boundaries aren't
what's going to divide you it's going to
be her choice to either violate or to
uphold those boundaries that you put out
there and she's an adult she gets to
make those choices yep uh Jody thanks
for calling I hope that helps